we just got an insane bombshell amount
of leaks for the 15-inch MacBook Air
that is coming soon yes I believe it's
actually coming next month at Apple's
March event and all the puzzle pieces
are finally coming together with a bunch
of leaks that I have laid out for you
guys in this video and I actually have
two different theories it could be a 15
inch MacBook Air or it could be
something different and I'll explain
that in just a minute but first let's
jump into these leaks according to digi
times the MacBook Air is launching next
quarter yes next quarter now I know you
guys are going to say that digit times
is not reliable but check this out on
February 13th Ross young the guy who
gives us the best display leaks ever and
he's very very accurate he said that the
15-ish MacBook Air is launching in April
and even more detail he said early April
so essentially the timing lines up
perfectly because if we have a March
event near the end of March apple is
going to announce the 15-inch MacBook
Air but it's only gonna ship in early
April so it matches up here and it
matches up to digit times leak as well
and the interesting thing here is that
he says that it's going to come with a
new 15.5 inch display now previously he
said 15.2 inches but now it's going to
be even bigger almost as big as this 16
inch MacBook Pro because this has a 16.2
inch display that's going to be 15.5 it
is going to be nuts now I know some of
you guys think that Apple's AR headset
is coming at the March event but no it
just got delayed once again Mark German
just said this it's not coming until
WWDC so what could potentially come at
the March event well first of all we
already got a report from Mark German
saying that no iMacs are expected to
launch and tell at least late 2023 or
early 2024 so it's not going to be an
iMac with the M2 Chip sorry iMac fans
it's also not going to be an updated Mac
Studio with the M2 Ultra chip a lot of
you guys thought it would be that but
Mark German says it is unlikely to be
launching because of this similarity
with the upcoming Mac Pro since the Mac
Pro is not going to have an M2 extreme
chip they're going to be too similar so
Apple might even completely skip the M2
Ultra model of the Mac Studio it's also
not going to be an iPad because the iPad
Pro is rumored to not be launching until
next year with an OLED display we also
just got the iPad 10 so it can't be that
we got the iPad Air in Spring of last
year so it's too soon for that so no
iPads at the March event for sure so
basically with that said the only thing
left is the 15 inch MacBook Air and
probably the Mac Pro but that is for
another video now a lot of you guys
think that the MacBook Air is going to
be coming with an M3 chip yes M3 but no
that is not coming until the second half
of 2023 check out this leak from
digitize the new Macbook Air with a
three nanometer M3 chip yes three
nanometer is coming in the second half
of 2023 so I think either October or
November which is perfect because it's
about a year and a half after the launch
of the M2 Chip the M2 MacBook Air so
it's the perfect 1.5 year timeline and
by the way we just got this leak Apple
has apparently ordered the entire supply
of tsmc's three nanometer chips for the
iPhone 15 Pro and M3 Max yes it's all
going to be three nanometer they're
gonna have enough supply for it 45
000 Wafers output starting in March
that's going to be insane so if you want
to wait for the three nanometer MacBook
Air you might want to do that for later
this year but I believe the 15 inch is
only going to come with the M2 and
especially with this leak from digit
times saying that the 15 inch MacBook
Air will reportedly have just the M2
Chip so what does that mean I believe it
means that the 15 inch MacBook Air is
going to be literally identical to the T
to the 13 inch MacBook Air the same
specs the same chip same performance no
fan the only difference will be the
larger size with the larger display
probably a bigger battery inside and
probably some better speakers as well
that's it no other differences and even
better we just got another leak of Apple
filing a Bluetooth 5.3 listing amid
rumors of a new Macbook Air and Mac Pro
so that could be point pointing to the
MacBook Air being ready to launch next
month and ship early April with of
course Bluetooth 5.3 so so many puzzle
pieces are coming together but wait
here's where it gets a little bit
interesting and way different here's the
second theory about what this 15-inch
MacBook could be way back in June of
last year mini Chico said that a new
15-inch MacBook with M2 and M2 Pro chip
options as being planned for
2023 which sounds completely weird but
looking closely at his tweet it says
that the 15-inch MacBook could launch in
the second quarter of 2023 which matches
up to all of the other leaks nicely but
it has the two chip options the M2 with
the 35 watt adapter and the M2 Pro with
the 67 watt adapter but the crazy thing
right here is that he says it might not
be called the Mac book air wait a minute
then what could it be called well Joe
resignal for Mac rumors made a very good
point in this tweet that could explain
how Apple updates the air with the M3
chip later this year without it feeling
unusually soon after this 15-inch
MacBook because a lot of people are
saying hey if there's an M3 MacBook Air
coming later this year why would Apple
release a 15-inch MacBook Gear with an
M2 right now it makes no sense they
should just combine them together just
like the 14 and 16 inch MacBook Pro
release them together but if they don't
call it the MacBook Air if they just
call it the 15-inch MacBook then it's on
its own cycle its own update and release
cycle and then that way it could
actually make sense for it to not be
limited to the same specs and details
and features as the regular MacBook Air
because then maybe you could have a fan
if it's the 15 inch MacBook maybe it can
have the M2 Pro chip option and and just
today Joe tweeted out again saying that
he does believe the 15-inch Macbook will
have an M2 Chip and it might even be
called just the Macbook without any air
branding and then it would sit perfectly
between the regular MacBook Air and the
MacBook Pro 2014 inch on the high end so
here is his perfect MacBook lineup
13-inch MacBook Air with the M2 Chip 15
inch MacBook with M2 and M2 Pro 14 and
16 inch MacBook Pros with M2 Pro and M2
Max that is a MacBook lineup that I
could get behind that is finally making
sense and getting rid of that really
weird 13-inch M2 MacBook Pro which is
garbage it should just be discontinued
by now so basically my take on that is
that if it is a 15 inch MacBook then it
justifies it being more expensive than
the M2 13-inch MacBook Pro at around
1400 or 1500 and replacing that model
completely finally fixing the lineup
finally making sense no more confusion
and then that way it doesn't have to
play by the MacBook Air their rules it
could have an M2 Pro option but of
course who knows this is my second
theory and there's still a chance that
this is still going to be the 15 inch
MacBook Air identical specs to the 13
inch no differences there that's the
first Theory so let me know which one
you think is more likely down in the
comment section below and if you enjoyed
this video you're excited for this
MacBook Air click the circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next one
foreign